theoretisch sollte ich gar nicht hier
sein und ihr übrigens auch nicht und
auch die Erde die Sonne die Milchstraße
und alles andere was wir hier gerade
sehen auch nicht aber wir sind ja hier
und das ist eines der größten Mysterien
der Physik das Problem ist die
Antimaterie laut Albert Einsteins
Relativitätstheorie lassen sich Masse
und Energie ineinander umwandeln und
beim Urknall ist sehr viel Energie in
sehr viel Masse umgewandelt worden der
Vorgang nennt sich Paarbildung denn es
entsteht dabei für jedes Teilchen
Materie auch ein Teilchen Antimaterie
bei Urknall entstand also nach unserem
Wissensstand gleich viel Materie und
Antimaterie das Ding ist nur wenn sich
Materie und Antimaterie treffen dann
wandeln sie sich sofort wieder in reine
Energie um das nennt sich
anilihation direkt nach dem Urknall
hätte sich also eigentlich jegliche
Materie gleich wieder mit Antimaterie
annihilieren müssen aber wir sind hier
es gibt Materie und von Antimaterie
fehlt jede Spur wo ist also der
Fehler bevor es losgeht möchte ich euch
noch die Naturschutzorganisation Planet
wild ans Herz legen die mit ihren
Projekten für den Erhalt von Ökosystemen
einsteht ich bin da selbst großer Fan
von und deswegen verschenke ich auch
wieder den ersten Monatsbeitrag für die
ersten 200 Leute die sich über den Link
in der Videobeschreibung anmelden und
mehr dazu erfahrt ihr am Ende des Videos
also wieso existieren wir überhaupt
wieso gibt es keine Antimaterie mehr das
ist etwas was Forscherinnen und Forscher
schon seit Jahrzehnten herausfinden
wollen der populärste Erklärungsversuch
ist dass beim Urknall doch ein kleines
bisschen mehr Materie als Antimaterie
entstanden sein muss auf eine Milliarde
Antiteilchen kamen eine Milliarde und
ein Teilchen und die ganze Materie die
wir jetzt beobachten aus denen wir
bestehen und aus denen alles um uns
herum besteht ist das was nach der
Annihilation übrigblie eben ist das
könnte bedeuten dass Materie und
Antimaterie vielleicht doch nicht ganz
genau Antiteilchen voneinander sind
vielleicht gibt es ja doch einen kleinen
Unterschied der dazu führt dass ein
bisschen mehr Materie entstanden ist als
Antimaterie ob das so ist und was dieser
Unterschied sein könnte dazu gibt uns
die Theorie leider keinen Hinweis für
die physikerinnen und Physiker heißt es
deshalb nachmessen und weil man
Antimaterie nicht einfach so in der
Natur findet muss man sie erst einmal
herstellen das geht aber nur mit extrem
komplizierten und sehr teuren Maschinen
und deswegen wird das nur an einem
einzigen Ort auf der ganzen Welt gemacht
am zern das ist eine
kernforschungseinrichtung zwischen der
Schweiz und Frankreich und ich habe sie
besucht und mit einem der führenden
Wissenschaftler dort gesprochen alle
Experimente mit Antimaterie weltweit
sind hier also alle nirgendwo son es
gibt nirgendwo sonst Antiprotonen und
das heißt nirgendwo sonst
antiwasserstoff oder diese Art
Experimente es ist nur hier sechs
Experimente die sich den Raum teilen die
Antiprotonen teilen und sonst natürlich
in Konkurrenz miteinander stehen aber
man geht dann trotzdem zusammen zur
Cafeteria ab und zu und nicht immer und
nicht mit allen okay die Antimaterie
wird mit Hilfe des Protonen Synchroton
einem Teilchenbeschleuniger hergestellt
ein Teilchenbeschleuniger ist ein
kreisrunder Tunnel in dem Teilchen
mittels Magneten in der Spur gehalten
und in dieselbe Richtung beschleunigt
werden am Ende hat man einen
Teilchenstrahl den man mit irgend
kollidieren lassen kann und dann misst
man was bei der Kollision so passiert so
lernt man dann etwas über die
entstehenden
Elementarteilchen das Protonen
Synchrotron erzeugt einen Strahl aus
Protonen also positiv geladener
Wasserstoffionen diesen Strahl schießt
man dann auf eine iridiumscheibe die
Energie die beim Einschlag frei wird
wandelt sich teilweise in verschiedene
Arten von Teilchen antiteilchenparen um
vor allem entstehen dabei leichte
Teilchen wie mionen und Elektronen aber
in einer von einer Million Kollisionen
entsteht auch mal ein Proton Antiproton
paar um die Antiprotonen weiter zu
verwenden müssen Sie jetzt erstmal
verlangsamt werden das macht man mit
zwei Antimaterie entschleunigern die
funktionieren wie Teilchen Beschleuniger
nur dass sie die Teilchen halt
verlangsamen statt beschleunigen sie
bringen die Antiprotonen von fast
Lichtgeschwindigkeit auf ein hunderel
der Lichtgeschwindigkeit herunter etwa
10,8 Millionen km pro Stunde das ist für
ein Proton tatsächlich ziemlich langsam
jeder protonenuls erzeugt am Ende eine
Wolke aus etwa 10 bis 40 Millionen
Antiprotonen und das ist dann
Antimaterie und falls sie befürchtet
dass diese Antimaterie eine große Gefahr
darstellt weil sie ja beim anhilieren
super viel Energie freisetzen kann dann
kann euch dr dosa beruhigen wir haben
ein milliardstelgramm im Jahr
zusammengesammelt und damit kann man
gerade mal so ein kleine teetaste zum
Kochen bringen okay also keine
Antimaterie Bombe wie bei
Illuminati die Antiprotonen können jetzt
entweder gleich untersucht werden oder
man wandelt sie noch in
antiwasserstoffatome um die haben dann
den Vorteil elektrisch neutral zu sein
um ein antiwasserstoffatom zu bekommen
fügt man zu einem negativ geladenen
Antiproton ein positiv geladenes
antielektron also ein Positron hinzu so
wird die elektrische Ladung ausgeglichen
der Prozess ist aber sehr ineffizient
und man bekommt aus den 10 bis 40
Millionen Antiprotonen am Ende nur etwa
10 bis 40 antiwasserstoffatome heraus
trotzdem ziemlich cool okay wir haben
jetzt also Antiprotonen und
antiwasserstoffatome mit denen können
die Forschenden am CERN jetzt
experimentieren sie wollen herausfinden
ob sich die Antiteilchen doch irgendwie
von normalen Teilchen unterscheiden das
könnte dann erklären warum wir heute
hier sind und nicht kurz nach dem
Urknall einfach weg annihilert wurden
also unsere Materie weil wir sind ja
sternstaub und so ihr wisst was ich
meine okay wie könnte sich so ein
antimaterieteilchen von einem
Materieteilchen unterscheiden der
Theorie nach sollten die Antiteilchen
einfach die exakten Spiegelbilder
normaler Teilchen sein dabei bleiben die
Masse die Lebensdauer und der Spin
gleich gespiegelt sind die Ladungen der
Teilchen Ladungen beschreiben die
Wechselwirkungen mit drei der vier
Grundkräfte also während ein Elektron
bekannterweise elektrisch negativ
geladen ist ist ein antielektron auch
Positron genannt elektrisch positiv
geladen und ein Proton ist elektrisch
positiv geladen während ein Antiproton
elektrisch negativ geladen ist das
Antiteilchen zu einem elektrisch
neutralen Teilchen wie dem Neutron ist
auch elektrisch neutral und die Ladung
bestimmt wie die Teilchen mit der
elektromagnetischen Kraft interagieren
in einem elektrischen Feld wandern
positive Teilchen zu Minuspol und
negative zum Pluspol und neutrale werden
einfach gar nicht beeinflusst zusätzlich
zu elektromagnetischen Kraft gibt es
noch die starke und die schwache
Wechselwirkung diese Kräfte bestimmen
was in einem Atom passiert sie
verhindern z.B dass Elektronen in
Atomkerne stürzen oder dass Atomkerne
einfach auseinander fliegen auch bei
diesen Kräften spricht man jeweils von
positiven negativen und neutralen
Ladungen und genau wie beim
Elektromagnetismus stoßen sich gleiche
Ladungen ab ungleiche Ladungen ziehen
sich an und neutrale Teilchen haben gar
keine Wechselwirkung auch die
Gravitation zählt zu den Grundkräften
aber so etwas wie eine massige Ladung
gibt es laut der Theorie nicht Masse
wirkt immer anziehend es gibt keine
negative Masse was ein bisschen schade
ist weil das würde uns ja tatsächlich
bei Wurmlöchern und beim teleportieren
helfen weil antimaterieteilchen und
normale Materieteilchen Spiegelbilder
voneinander sind also in einigen
Eigenschaften genau gleich sind und in
anderen Eigenschaften das genaue
Gegenteil spricht man auch von Symmetrie
und diese Symmetrie wollen die
Forscherinnen und Forscher jetzt
ausmessen denn wenn die Symmetrie nicht
perfekt ist dann könnte das die Antwort
auf die Frage sein wieso es heute noch
normale Materie im Universum gibt und
keine Antimaterie im Projekt Base wird
von einzelnen Antiprotonen ein ganzes
Jahr lang jede Minute die Masse die
Ladung und das magnetische Moment
gemessen das vergleicht man mit
Messungen an negativ geladenen
Wasserstoffionen und es ist ziemlich
cool dass man Antimaterie so lange
aufrecht erhalten kann 2022
veröffentlichte das Projekt ein
allererstes Zwischenergebnis zum
Verhältnis von Masse zu
elektromagnetischer Ladung und sie
fanden heraus dass es keinen Unterschied
gibt in anderen Projekten misst man
welche Wellenlänge des Lichts antiatome
anregt vor einigen Jahren zeigte das
alpateam auf diese Weise das erste Mal
den Übergang von Positronen in einen
höheren Energiezustand das ist super
krass dass sie das geschafft haben aber
auch sie fanden leider keinen
nennenswerten Unterschied zu normaler
Materie Dr Michael Doser möchte in
seinem Projekt Aegis messen wie
Antimaterie mit der Schwerkraft
interagiert dazu wollen sie erst einmal
einen langsamen Strahl von
antiwasserstoffatomen herstellen wie
Kanonenkugeln aus einer Kanone
geschossen kommen dann die einzelnen
antiwasserstoffatome heraus fliegen auf
einer parabelbahn fallen über eine
gewisse Distanz und wenn wir die
Flugzeit kennen und die Distanz die sie
gefallen sind haben wir die Gravitation
gemessen allerdings ist die Konkurrenz
vom Alpha g Projekt das natürlich auch
am CERN arbeitet gerade einen kleinen
wird voraus sie haben
antiwasserstoffatome aus einer
Magnetfalle in einen vertikalen Zylinder
entlassen und dann gemessen ob sie eher
oben oder unten gegen die Wand prallen
und
annihileren letztes Jahr meldeten sie
Antimaterie fällt nach unten Wu die
vorhin beschriebene Theorie wurde also
soweit wieder bestätigt Antimaterie wird
von Masse angezogen so wie Materie auch
ob sie aber genauso stark angezogen wird
das ist wegen der relativ geringen
Präzision der Messung noch nicht klar
alles in allem haben die Forschungsteams
am CERN mit ihren nie daagewesenen
Messungen bisher keinen Unterschied
zwischen Antimaterie und Materie
gefunden die Voraussagen der
Quantenphysik stehen also Wien 1 noch
denn einen Grund muss es ja dafür geben
dass wir existieren dass hier überall
Materie ist für die Beteiligten
physikerinnen und Physiker heißt das die
Messungen müssen noch präziser werden so
hat Alpha g die Wirkung von Schwerkraft
auf Antimaterie mit einer Genauigkeit
von 30% gemessen Michael Doser strebt
eine Genauigkeit von 1% an die
Experimente werden also laufend weiter
entwickelt verbessert und ausgebaut die
Forschenden am zern fanden auch heraus
dass man viele weitere
antimaterieeteilchen herstellen kann z.B
antiprotonisches Helium bei dem in einem
konventionellen heliumatom ein Elektron
gegen ein Antiproton ausgetauscht wurde
oder protonium ein Atom das aus einem
Antiproton und einem Proton besteht die
umeinander kreisen ohne sich zu
annihilieren bei einem positronium
Kreisen ein Elektron und ein Positron
umeinander protonium und positronium
Atome kann Dr Michael dosa auch mit
seiner Apparatur messen wir können jetzt
ein bisschen geschickter Vorgehen als
ursprünglich gedacht indem wir
verschiedene Systeme miteinander
vergleichen einerseits wird man dadurch
die Systematik los andererseits ist man
dann empfindlich auf Kräfte die wir
nicht kennen die thetisch seind man
sucht am CERN also nicht nur nach dem
mysteriösen smetriebruch der Antimaterie
sondern z.B auch nach bisher unbekannten
physikalischen Kräften oder nach
Kandidaten für die Dunkle Materie auch
die ist ein heißes Thema beim zern aber
ich glaube darüber sprechen wir ein
ander mal mein Besuch am CERN war total
faszinierend ich fand es mega spannend
ich konnte mit interessanten Menschen
über die großen Mysterien der Physik und
die Arbeit am CERN sprechen man darf da
sicher auf viele aufregende Entdeckungen
gespannt sein also abonniert gerne
unseren Kanal um das nicht nicht zu
verpassen übrigens wir haben mit Michael
dosa viel länger gesprochen als wir
jetzt hier gerade reinschneiden konnten
das ganze Interview ist über eine halbe
Stunde lang und super spannend wir haben
das ganze Interview auf
patreon.com/d watatson veröffentlicht
für alle die uns da unterstützen vielen
Dank dafür und ansonsten hat Michael
Doser noch sehr spannende Ideen und
sucht nach jüngeren Kollegen die diese
Ideen am CERN ausprobieren wollen also
wenn ihr Interesse habt dann meldet euch
gerne bei ihm und bevor ihr jetzt alle
beim CERN anruft habe ich noch etwas für
euch auch wenn wir noch nicht wissen
warum wir exist eren wissen wir ziemlich
genau was passieren muss damit wir noch
ein bisschen länger existieren ein Team
aus Berlin weiß ganz genau wovon ich
spreche und arbeitet daran dass uns mehr
Zeit zur Lösung physikalischer Mysterien
bleibt die Rede ist natürlich von Planet
wild das ist eine
Naturschutzorganisation die jeden Monat
ein großes Projekt durchführt um unseren
Planeten zu bewahren und die Schäden zu
beheben die die Menschen der Natur
zufügen diese Projekte sind aber auf die
monatlichen Beiträge einer Community
angewiesen die die Erhaltung unserer
Ökosysteme unterstützen möchte wenn ihr
also schon länger den Wunsch hattet
etwas für die Erhaltung der Natur zu tun
dann ist die Unterstützung einer
Organisation wie Planet wild schon ein
sehr guter Anfang außerdem produzieren
die sehr coole und interessante Youtube
vide was ich echt toll finde da sieht
man einfach direkt was die Community
gemeinsam bewirkt und dass die Gelder
tatsächlich ankommen wenn ihr also auch
ein Teil dieser Community werden wollt
dann ist jetzt ein guter Zeitpunkt denn
wie am Anfang des Videos gesagt bekommen
die ersten 200 Personen die sich über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung
anmelden ihren ersten Monat bei Planet
wild von mir geschenkt und wenn ihr noch
nicht restlos überzeugt seid dann findet
ihr hier noch ein Video über Hunde die
bedrohte Schildkröten vor wilderan
beschützen viel Spaß beim weiterschauen
also und wie immer bleibt neugierig euer
Cedrick